Our breathing can deepen
and become irregular.
Our heart starts to race,
our pupils dilate
which might be one
of the reasons so many people
close their eyes during a kiss.
There are three sensations
that one should really recognise
when they're kissing.
First of all there's the
wonderful feeling of touch
because our lips
are extremely sensitive,
we have more nerve neurons
on the end of our lips
than any other place
in our body,
except some areas in our genitalia.
And then of course
also there's taste.
Each individual has
a unique taste to them
and some people are much better
at recognising taste than others
and then of course
there's also smell.
Ovid in some of his poems
talked about kisses smelling
like ripening apples in a chest.
There's a lot of theories
as to why we kiss
but some of it may have to do
with our earliest experiences
on planet Earth.
When we're infants,
through being kissed by parents
and also through nursing,
through a lot of lip stimulation
that becomes associated through
neural pathways in our brain
with these very, very
positive emotions.
And so we're building
these neural pathways
that attribute kissing and lip
stimulation with love and security
and all of these wonderful things
that later in life when we want
to express ourselves that way,
we probably do so
using our mouth.
While we can't zip
ourselves back in time
and kind of discover when
and where and how the first kiss
took place among humans,
what we do know is that other species
are very attracted to the
rosy bottoms of females
when they're at peak fertility,
when they're in estrus.
There are some anthropologists
that think that the lips
are what's called 'the genital echo'
so they mimic the female genitals
in shape, composition,
colour and texture,
and they serve as reliable indicator
of when a woman
might be ready to mate.
Desmond Morris, a British zoologist,
he's actually done
some research on lipstick,
showing different men
images of women's faces
asking who the most
attractive are?
And over and over and over men are
consistently choosing the women
who are expressing the rosiest
most coloured lips in these studies.
So there's something that
does draw our attention to the mouth
and the colour red
is a colour that many species
use to exhibit this sexual signal.
The earliest evidence that
we find of any kind of kissing
is about 2,500 maybe 3,500 years ago,
in some of the early Vedic texts
that come from India.
It turns out that the area right
below your eyes has sebaceous glands
that produce a unique
smell for each individual.
So these ancient Indians in northern
India were sniffing each other
and of course if they ran their noses
across the cheeks of each other
and then across the nose
to the other side of the cheek,
I think that occasionally
some of them slipped
and may have ended up on the lips
and because the lips
are so sensitive,
they may have found that that
was much more pleasurable
than just sniffing each other.
The Romans can
be looked upon really as
probably the first
great kissing culture.
They had different kinds of kissing.
The savium was what we
might call a French kiss.
Based on the word saliva
which we still use today
and of course they enjoyed
practicing this all the time.
There's places where people just
thought kissing was disgusting
which might not be that surprising
when you consider that
for the most part, people weren’t
brushing their teeth and flossing,
using mouthwash and all
these things we do today,
where it would probably be a lot
less appetising not that long ago.
However, it's something that
even where we didn’t do that
we were sniffing, we were patting,
we were licking
and sucking and nibbling
and doing things all about
each other's bodies to connect
and that connection is ultimately
important for keeping us together,
for keeping our bonds strong,
for raising all of the different
hormones and neurotransmitters
in our bodies that make us maintain
our important relationships.
And kissing is a big part of that.